Wong – like, Adele? As of "Spider-Man: No
Way Home," it's more like "Sorcerer Supreme."
Tom Holland's Spider-Man is unlike
anything we've seen before from the
web-slinger on the big screen. In earlier
movies, Peter Parker often acted as a
lone wolf. He worked by himself and never seemed
to encounter other superheroes in his world,
even in New York City, home to most of
the Marvel universe's superheroes. This
changed pretty drastically with the character's
introduction into the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
where he has had plenty of opportunities to
fight alongside Earth's mightiest heroes.
"Cap'n. Big fan. Spider-Man."
"Yeah, we'll talk about it later."
"Hey everyone."
"Good job."
In "Captain America: Civil War" and "Spider-Man:
Homecoming," he was a protégé of Iron Man.
In "Spider-Man: Far From Home," he had to
try to live up to Tony Stark's expectations
in the aftermath of Iron Man's death. And, in
"Spider-Man: No Way Home," Peter turns to a member
of his old "Avengers: Infinity War" cohort,
Doctor Strange, to help him out of a pinch.
As "No Way Home" begins, Peter's dealing
with the ramifications of having his
identity exposed to the world. He turns
to the Bleecker Street sorcerer to cast a
spell so that no one will remember that Peter
Parker and Spider-Man are one and the same.
It's at this moment we get an intriguing
new bit of information about a key player,
and it's something every MCU fan
maybe should have seen coming.
After Peter shows up, Doctor Strange and Wong
discuss the ethical and practical ramifications
of casting a spell that will impact everyone
on the planet, including themselves. It's at
this point Wong makes it known he is now the
Sorcerer Supreme, and it makes total sense.
In "Infinity War," Wong is left to protect
the Sanctum Sanctorum when Ebony Maw takes
Strange prisoner. While the movie makes it
unclear if Wong is a casualty of The Blip,
the actor who plays him, Benedict Wong, confirmed
in a 2019 Reddit AMA that he would likely take
over as Sorcerer Supreme. Although Strange
was originally tapped to hold the title,
he was gone for five years, courtesy of Thanos.
Naturally, the title had to go to someone else,
considering everyone thought
Strange was permanently dead.
The revelation about Wong's new status
within the sorcerer hierarchy provides
new context to an exchange featured
in the "No Way Home" teaser trailer:
"Don't cast that spell. It's too dangerous."
"Fine. I won't."
We now know that order isn't coming from
a peer. it's coming from someone
who's effectively Strange's boss.
What does this mean for the future of the
MCU? Probably not much. Doctor Strange still
has full control of his powers, including his
ability to manipulate reality per his whims.
Wong will likely still be Sorcerer Supreme
going into "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness," but that likely won't stop
Strange from messing with other realities and
interacting with Scarlet Witch along
the way. It's simply a title change,
though it's one that Wong probably
won't want to give up any time soon.
Wong as the Sorcerer Supreme makes sense,
but one aspect of his new role that may
have fans scratching their heads is why
such a powerful individual spends their
time fighting in underground cage fights.
As Marvel fans will remember, Wong
was part of Xialing's superpowered
tournament in "Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings."
Such an act might make sense for a sorcerer
who's short on rent money for the month.
But doesn't the Sorcerer Supreme have better
things to do than break The Abomination out
of a high-security prison to battle him in
front of a bunch of spectators and gamblers?
Maybe Wong just loves the thrill of the
fight. Perhaps he's having trouble paying
off the homeowner's tax for the Sanctum Sanctorum.
It's undoubtedly expensive right smack dab
in the middle of Manhattan. Either way, it
appears that Doctor Strange isn't the only wizard
who's willing to bend the rules a little bit.
The real question remains whether Wong will retain
the title of Sorcerer Supreme or if Strange will
take it back at some point in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness." Time will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.